في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا على
حاكم كلغ الروسيه انظمه الدفاع الجوي
اسقطت مسيره في سماء المقاطعه جنوب غرب
موسكو فجر اليوم ان جانبه اعلن الجيش
الروسيا وحدات مجموعه الغرب التابعه للجيش
سيطرت على سبعه مواقع تابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه ودمرت سريه مشاف في منطقه
اولشان
[موسيقى]
من جهتها قلت النيابه العامه الاوكرانيه
ان امراه قتلت واصيب سبعه اخرون في قصف
روسي على مقاطعه خرسون جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا
واضافه النيابه العامه في بيان ان القصف
استهدف حيا سكانيا في مركز المدينه ادى
الى اشتعال النيران في المبنى وتضرر عدد
من الابنيه المجاوره
في هذه الاثناء قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات
بثلاثين صاروخا ونفذت اثنتين وخمسين غار
جويه كما اطلقت 75 مقذوفا من رجمات
الصواريخ خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه وهذا ادى الى مقتل واصابه عدد من
المدنيين كما قالت الهيئه ان قوتها تصدت
لمحاولات التقدم روسيه على اتجاهات
كوبيانس كافيه مقاطعه
خارقيافكا في مقاطعه بينما واصلت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجومها في محوري
في مقاطعه ذا فوروشيا واشارت الهيئه في
بيان الى ان خطوط المواجهه بين الطرفين
شهدت 50 اشتباكا ونفذ الطيران الاوكراني
واربع عشره غاره على مواقع القوات الروسيه